[Applause]
think am i little thanks for saying i'm
little yeah a little cracker i've never
done that oh well it's a step up from
the hat you were wearing earlier
not really that's how it's like your
skin why does that hat say thank you
porcelain and beautiful yeah so many and
it says cannabis on it i don't know what
is it why does it say cannabis because
it's from a cannabis store
this is very out of character
today was you're moving before this had
so many times around you no you haven't
yes i have this is like when you ask me
every time if my glasses are real
[Music]
they do look like a harry potter costume
yeah tell me i'm wrong that's from willy
wonka let's go
i'm not willy wonka i by the way
this brings me this brings me to some of
the videos you shot of me in uh
milwaukee last week where i looked like
a who
i
love when you do your hair like that i
love it it's not doing my hair it's
waking up i'm not and you don't tell me
that it looks crazy
and then you're just sabotaging me and
then you're like how come you don't have
beauty campaigns i'm like because you
don't tell me
it wasn't i mean it was crazy i got you
to have a beauty campaign that's so
funny i look like a who from i was
wondering like i've cracked out who
likes
i look like jared leto in dallas buyer's
club
yeah
i just look insane and i'm asking it's a
it's it was an ad for uh it was one of
our sponsors for sleep crowd and i'm i'm
it looked like a turd on your head i'm
trying to make people take me seriously
well to be fair
one of us did pitch waiting through the
ad and you said let's just do it now
that's the truth but you could have been
like hey do you want to maybe run a
brush through that fucking steel wool
nightmare i gave my i gave my two cents
and you said i don't want that change no
you didn't i said let's wait and do this
later but that's not a specific like hey
just can you redo your hair i bet you
learn to trust me next time won't you no
i look like phil spector
yeah i stand to wait but that you know
hey let's wait you look insane you say
that there's a nice way to say i would
never say that you do say it when we're
not rolling all the time just be like
looking cute
looking real
i guess you just accept me for who i am
you need to go to a psychiatrist named
dr seuss um as far as i'm concerned
today speaking of serious
influential people that are respected by
millions
robert greene
is the interview today this is the
second time on the podcast his first
interview was a mind betting thrill ride
huge people loved it he has a new book
out called the daily laws you know that
he wrote uh the 48 laws of power he
wrote my favorite book on the planet
mastery the art of seduction uh the art
of war the 50th law which i think 50
cent is making into a movie or a tv show
or something yeah it's like every
anything with 50 in it anything like 50.
he's like that's on branch yes that's my
guess that's mine that's me
i was trying to think of more things
over 50.
victoria pedretti's little brother that
died and you
his name's 50. no it's 40. damn it damn
it damn not on brand god damn it
uh and uh
the laws of human nature these books all
changed my life they're how i learned to
uh accept human nature unconditionally
and be a leader and think critically and
uh lean into
what power really means
and uh
a lot of time in what seduction really
means and how to stop being annoying and
grading and that's one of the art of
seduction laws is talk don't talk as
loud so people have to lean into you so
you didn't read the book
because i read it in the art of
seduction
benton's rubbing nipple they're nipples
you know if i have nipples there or not
i truly at this point don't know where
anything on your body is
so
this intros made you dumber so now if
you listen to this interview it will get
your brain cells back in working order
uh i am obsessed with robert green he's
one of the few people that i will not be
able to interrupt no matter how bad my
tourette's gets and how much my add
tries to take over
um and make me uh
he's i just love him he's my he's big
daddy energy he's one of the few men
that i
listen to
or
like want to listen to or like don't
disassociate when they're talking you
know
he's one of the few men that if they
tripped and fall if he tripped and fell
in front of me i would think it was hot
oh that because that's my name
from you that's very hybrid many men
that i've been in love with have tripped
and fall and that was it that's it it
was over once i see any kind of weakness
i can't my like primordial brain just
you're out you checked out it's such a
bummer and i have no control over it but
he i could see him trip and fall and i'd
be like i just love you more yeah
good good idea be vulnerable in front of
people to get more power
genius twisted brain of yours
uh i'm bringing this twisted brain of
mine to boise idaho
to twist it up even more last time i was
in boise the venue that i was booked in
caught on fire and i ended up doing a
drag club instead which was honestly
really fun
um but i'm gonna be at the egyptian
theater this time
and
i think that's that's where we keep your
sarcophagus
is
well my favorite song is still walk like
an egyptian but i feel like it got
cancelled bummer uh there's limited
tickets also uh seattle 12-4 i'm gonna
be there neptune theater sold out for
sure there's not limited tickets because
here's the thing is that these these
shows have been rescheduled so many
times and it's been like a year and a
half that a lot of the people who bought
tickets no longer even live in that city
so there's tickets that become available
there's people that are like hey i
bought these tickets like two years ago
and now like when i was for like a
bachelorette party and now i have two
children and can't come like there's now
some people are dead people like i live
in minneapolis i died of covet like i
can't be there i die i can't be i can't
be there like there's plenty of people
who i hate might get that message to my
ouija board
i can't believe thank god okay
okay can we resell those tickets and so
uh jenna friedman will be joining us who
is a brilliant brilliant brilliant uh in
addition to one benton ray on december
9th i'm going to be in columbus ohio at
the jo ann davidson theater can't sell a
ticket to save my life because you keep
making fun of joanne columbus i i am a
joanne stan
joe stan your favorite fabric
pete davidson's aunt
no one like i just i o columbus is just
not i don't know if you just don't
listen to podcast i don't know how to
get to you maybe we should run an ad in
the paper in the parade magazine the
back the back
we should sell her on a ship and just
claim the land i don't know had it like
columbus i have people i just don't
think you guys either listen to podcasts
or you fast forward to this first part
in which case you're just smarter than
than anyone else so joanne davidson
theater then i'm going to be in
cleveland 12 10 december 10th agora
theater if you're agoraphobic
tricky title for a theater you won't you
won't be there the agoraphobia
uh there's limited tickets you do like
me in cleveland uh uh
12 11 i'm coming to chicago my favorite
favorite favorite thing on the planet is
chicago where i'm doing a smaller venue
because i wanted to shoot a special at
the vic theater because i did something
that just for laughs there one year and
i was like it was maybe my favorite
venue i ever performed in so i really
want to come back here
i'll do chicago theater next year but
instead we're going to do two shows on
uh
december
11th chicago vic theater first show sold
out but show up anyway i'm sure there'll
be some spots um and the second show has
limited tickets chicago i love you i
cannot wait to come there and uh and
then
uh i'm gonna shut my whore mouth so that
you can listen to one of the greatest
philosophers and historians and the
greatest minds of our time robert green
and he doesn't just go on people's
podcast willy-nilly he does not he
really doesn't
we were shocked he came back i it is no
one knows what's going on
no one knows why he keeps doing our
podcast
maybe he's researching something you
know that i feel like he's his next book
is on like insecure narcissists
and the 48 laws of insecure narcissism
times three you've got three of them the
48 laws the examples of how not to be
the 48 laws of powerless and uh
and i have in my office i have a whole
section of just robert green books that
are
that are touched underlined down to
they're not like great gatsby books
those spines are cracked down to the
spine those spines look like my face
with that big bottom
the crow's feet are deep
uh i love you enjoy robert green please
[Music]
last time
last time robert green was here i i
unraveled
no you didn't you raveled i
i unraveled no i think the opposite i
broke apart and i had to put myself to
back together again
well
so i want i wrote okay you know what i
have so many questions written down i
just don't want this to be
too
logical to you want to just kind of you
know me you know me yeah because we're
real friends now i hope so
and we were just downstairs
and you gravitated towards a book about
nazis yes i did let's talk about them
well i'm jewish and um congrats thank
you there's no congrats for that
um
and you know a lot of my
family particularly on my father's side
probably perished in the holocaust
and
when i was a kid you know it was like i
was sort of obsessed with world war ii
and with german uniforms and german army
men i don't know why i found the gray
and the helmets so interesting
and then where on the street where i
grew up it was like a canyon
and we and the boys we had a game the
game was called gestapo
and in this game
one person would be like somebody who
had escaped from prison
and there i'm sorry there would be two
people who had escaped from prison but
they were on either sides of the canyon
and the object of the game was to find
each other and we had walkie-talkies
and the gestapo were the other four guys
on the neighborhood and they had like
dogs
like my one friend greg who i'm still
friends with he had like a bloodhound
and they'd be searching for us it was
the most nerve-wracking frightening game
you could imagine
you know
but anyway that could not be a uh
live-action show today
no it's not a tv show totally playing i
should crunch that
no
don't and
and so you know i just i just find the
the pageantry in a sick way
of like the great rallies and stuff
all the colors and the flags and the
pennants and everybody's singing all in
unison yeah to be like overwhelming it's
so weird what does overwhelming mean
overwhelming in a good way
i think in in a kind of a horror
horrifying way
but it kind of attracts me and repels me
at the same time
and what is that is that
called repugnant is that called uh
mystique
is that like like uh
when you want to want something you
you're grossed out by it but you want to
be near it
i don't know what my fascination is it's
something as i said
you know like as a boy i loved war i
have to admit it i can't disguise that
fact but i wrote a book on war yeah i
know basically don't all aren't we at
war all the time now every day
essentially isn't that what traffic is
yeah yeah are we at war we're wired to
be at war all the time yes exactly thank
you for saying that
emotionally and otherwise but isn't that
don't we recreate like that primordial
instinct to be at war in other ways now
whether it's like i'm on the phone with
my agent or i'm mad at my boyfriend are
we always kind of still fighting yeah
well that's that was the subject of my
third book this 33 strategies of war
where i saw warfare embedded in almost
all aspects of our daily life
like if you have a boyfriend or a spouse
that you don't get along with and you're
fighting all the time it is a form of
battle and conflict right and sometimes
one person is more strategic than the
other and they usually kind of win those
battles kind of thing it's not a very
healthy way of looking at human
relationships but it's also very true
and very real
it's so interesting like you know
we've talked about this maybe before but
my um
therapist says like we don't say healthy
we say helpful because
to say that's not healthy that's
pathologizing it's like but to say
that's not helpful is surrendering to
our nature it's like it's not healthy to
do this well humans aren't healthy we're
not wired to completely agree we're not
wired to to do things that are
necessarily moral we're wired to do
things that are beneficial you know so
healthy has a judgment on it
yeah you know that's like implies that
we have some kind of choice in the
matter when a lot of it is our human
nature yeah i agree with you well that's
you know it's precisely what i think and
what i write about so i hate watching
people interview you because they always
ask stupid questions oh please tell me
why
because it's like i can can you give me
an example which one does it be no i
cannot i'll get in trouble but i just
don't i don't like when people like so
tell me like how do you seduce someone
or like tell me
it's just like read the book so
i'm gonna ask you a bunch of questions
that you are have not been asked because
if you're watching this it means you're
you've read the books you're in a
wormhole you're going down the rabbit
hole on youtube of all your interviews
you're trying to start your company
you're getting out of a breakup you're
in a relationship you're going through a
divorce you're going to college
something is going on in your life where
you want to take your power back you
know where you want to take control of
your life and you are the
um singular authority
and inspiration in terms of how to do
that um you're uniquely qualified uh to
give those insights
my question
i i kind of want to start like did you
see this travis scott
is this big rapper yeah
i've read about it
and
they there was a surge of
people that surged toward the concert
they perished
eight people died oh
and then it made me remember remember
pearl jam
in the 90s had a similar situation in
germany
i think 11 people died in the pearl jam
surge i don't remember that now
um
like
what do you what does robert greene
think when he sees that headline
knowing how much you know about human
nature and well it's actually something
oh don't move ramona
she's lying on my foot sorry uh robert
and uh my dog ramona have a very intense
relationship and it comes before this
podcast yes
and i know that um well it's actually
something i'm writing a little bit about
in my new book on the sublime i just
wrote a chapter on that
and um it's i talk about paganism and
ancient religions
and um how paganism is still very much
alive in the modern world only we just
don't realize it
and so one of the manifestations of this
kind of paganism that still exists in
our world is people things like raves
and concerts like this one
and even those kind of rallies i was
talking about the nazis i'm not
comparing at all a concert with the
nazis don't get me wrong but the sense
of being in a group and a collective
and having all of that energy and
everybody kind of feeling the same thing
dopamine address and the oxytocin oh
incredible amounts of chemicals are in
operation in fact you're on drugs
already and then you're taking drugs
it's an intense human need we we kind of
want that feeling that feeling of
transcendence of being deeply enmeshed
in a group
and i say
i say in the chapter that i just wrote
that no one has read yet and won't read
for a few years
is that it's kind of the the pagan
aspect of our world today is the
opposite of everything that really of
all our true progressive values so we
value
being unique being an individual having
your own identity but secretly people
kind of want to lose themselves in a
crowd they go on to feel like they're in
that kind of collective they're sort of
one consciousness they want to get away
from all this individuality and they
want to kind of sink themselves
in the crowd now is that healthy or i'm
sorry helpful
i caught myself thank you or not i i'm
not going to say because i don't like
judging things i'm just saying that's
what i think is going on in the world
and so
there's something very primal that draws
people into these kind of concerts and
things and and kind of going berserk you
know do you think the pandemic uh had
any effect on it in terms of like the
the because at first i was like oh yeah
people have been cooped up in their
house it was kind of like a you know
like a um what's the thing where you
pull it back and the tension what is it
when you pull back pull pull back a
puppet string or something what do you
pull
and then you like oh like a bow and a
bow yeah like just there was so much
tension of people staying inside for so
long that they were like we're going to
a concert like i was looking for all
these other things
like modern things to blame but this is
a very primordial thing and it's
happened over and over and over again
and it happened in the 90s at pearl jam
um
uh 11 people died at a pearl jam concert
in uh
germany before and there was no pandemic
tension well you know we're a social
animal um and uh when you're cooped up
for
i don't know how long how many months we
were cooped up for and you don't have
any interaction with people i think
there's been a lot of a mental illness
that has been kind of creeping into a
lot of people
um because we depend so much on being
around other people for feeling like
we're human for feeling like we're alive
and being in a crowd
there there was um a great sociologist i
want to get too academic here on you
in the 19th century sort of the founder
of
sociology durkheim
and he said
this
the idea of god the feeling of god or
spirits or gods came from actually being
in a group situation and in a group you
feel a different energy
right if you're in a group of 100 people
at a concert or like you're flying yeah
you don't feel the same as when you're
alone
you become a different person right
you're an entity
and he thought that that energy that
kind of comes from the group is what we
then transformed into a god it's very
it's very controversial idea is it why i
don't know i find it very valid but some
people think that kind of diminishes the
idea of the spiritual realm it makes it
too
kind of human or whatever
as if there isn't such a real thing as
god's but anyway the the
the sense of being in a group we become
a different person right so we're here
in that group seeing travis scott on
that stage and there's 50 000 people
you've probably been taking drugs and
you're all packed together like that
there's all you know this at some point
for me it would be horrifying because
i'm claustrophobic but um
you know you feel you're like connected
with everyone else you're like
supercharged you're like more than human
and you have the adrenaline response and
when you have so much adrenaline you
feel less pain so your body might not
even be telling you how much damage is
being done to it you know so it's like
even
because i guess some people got like
physically crushed like but you you know
i remember when i had my ear bitten off
um
it didn't hurt
because uh all of this this was a dog by
the way a dog by the way he was not a
man
wasn't mike tyson i know you guys got
jealous for a second
it was not my tyson
um and uh
it
the all the oxytocin and norepinephrine
and phenylethylamine floods the area
fennel you know what's so funny i made a
movie about neuroscience and i had to i
was talking about this with benton this
weekend phenylethylamine what a word
emily do you remember phenylethylamine i
can't say that i do have somewhat of a
speech
impairment or impediment
um i'm sorry i don't mean to interrupt
go on with your story e
no i'm interrupting my your interruption
to go
phenylethylamine you say it
phenylethylamine that's how it's
it
when you say it even if you say it right
you sound like you have a speech
impediment phenylethylamine
m phenylethylamine you see you sound
drunk i am
can i get my pocket protector please yes
like it's phenylethylamine
phenylethylamine i think you're adding
an l nope phenyl
oh thank you that didn't sound right
okay so this means i pronounced it wrong
in the movie
well if somebody would have caught that
if you didn't no i think actor would
have i think i was supposed to guess
that's emily's job that's my bad on the
movie
well it's i directed it it was my job to
catch it you directed it yeah i directed
it and i was in it
phenylethy wait phenethylamine shit okay
so i definitely pronounced it wrong in
the movie
well comedy maybe you know this is a big
way that i came
to you okay because so because i get
such bad migraines
i can't uh
pre uh i get speech impediment when i
have a migraine coming on like i start
slurring yeah
which is how i
led me to learn about neurology and then
so when both of my parents had strokes i
already had a little bit of information
both of them the same what about that
yeah both of them the same year
i'm following in the footsteps of your
parents
and i'm following the footsteps of your
parents remember last time you were here
you told me i looked like your mom and i
was like uh oh
let's wrap this up
she's gonna be watching this by the way
okay hi
hi me hi me like looking in a mirror
um
and uh okay we're all over the place but
let me ask you a question so so you are
the authority on
all things power like as someone that
you know look i
you know
your books are
i always say imprinted in my dna
you know i love it when i'm giving you
the biggest compliment in your life
you're just like hi little doggy doggy
um
yes i'm sorry you're
i'm gonna focus now for real i'm really
sorry about this it's my fault but you
put that dog there don't i don't this is
what it doesn't have to this is what we
do i'm gonna focus um and we'll do many
many more um i hope and uh
i i struggle with which question to ask
how soon with you but you said i'm the
expert on power as the expert on power
and like as someone that is the
authority on how people rose to power
how people attain power maintain power
art of seduction
laws of power
is now an interest like what is your
definition of power i was thinking about
this last night i was like what is my
definition of power because i was
thinking about i was like i think power
is when you can
lay down on sleep whenever you're tired
[Laughter]
that's power
if you can take a nap whenever you want
well i guess i have a lot of power
you're either unemployed or super
powerful exactly so i don't know about
it because i was like thinking about it
last night i was like what does power
mean because
power
is
like you know and emeline and i were
talking about this earlier and
in relationships like when we give our
power away and give our tear power back
and stuff like that i was just like what
does it even mean anymore because a lot
of having power
especially in your new book is
relinquishing it a little bit and
letting other people think that they
have it
when they don't sometimes that's that's
definitely an aspect of it
you know um so to go back to kind of the
48 laws theory that kind of inspired the
book
we humans have an innate desire for
power for expansion for feeling like
what are you looking for i'm looking for
i love that you just call me i'm looking
for my copy of this this is your copy
this is my copy okay
um it's all marked up stuff on it so um
we have an innate desire for a feeling
of control over our environment right so
that we can kind of feel like we can
expand that we have freedom to move and
we have you know
maneuverability that we have some degree
of influence over the people around us
that our children our spouse our boss
our colleagues will listen to us sorry
mona has all the power right now she's
sneezing well she's she's a great
seductive
that was a really wet one
mona is sneezing while the king is
talking really cute that is a power mode
you're so cute to show a little
vulnerability exactly
so um
you know but the problem is so it's a
very primal need that we humans have
right and it goes back
to hundreds of thousands of years ago
because essentially we're kind of weak
um creatures compared to like a lion a
leopard a dog or trash bags full of
blood huh
i say we're trash bags full of blood oh
thank you that's very well put it's
basically what we are right and if you
look at us as infants no other animal
has infants that are so helpless for so
long right so we carry a great deal they
have a hole in their head they're born
with a hole in their head and they can't
even put their head up i didn't know
that
babies have a hole on the top of their
head what i learned when i come here
you know that
no you do know that it's a soft spot
it's just where their skull hasn't grown
it's not a hole it's just
i'm just getting scared
i was trying to feel it maybe i still
have a hole
um i took this uh uh attachment strategy
attachment strategy course yeah with
george haas and uh
they say um the chimpanzee studies
because we're basically you know bonobo
apes and
us have more similar dna than african
elephants and indian elephants yeah yeah
it's very true so
uh bonobo apes they're
babies when left in the wild
the amount of time they can survive
alone in the wild
without their parents
one day
yeah
one day right
so
because of our physical vulnerabilities
we have a tremendous desire for some
kind of power or control because we're
essentially very weak physically
okay but then you come into the modern
world and i would say modern like five
six hundred years ago
where
to be kind of brutal and want to get
your power directly and pushing people
around
is very counterproductive you're going
to make everybody hate you
and so when you enter the realm of
democracy where you've got millions of
people in a country that are all
striving for some kind of power
you have to be very careful and you have
to be very indirect right i compare it
to the courts of europe like in louis
xiv court
where you had you wanted to get closer
to the king and get the king to
recognize you but if you tried too hard
to signal to the king and get his
approval all the other courtiers hated
you and they would stab you in the back
because they are repelled by needy
energy
yes and we'll mostly kiss ass or try
hard yeah well the king is repelled by
it but everyone else is vying for the
same attention if you're trying too hard
it signals weakness like you were saying
yeah signals weakness because yeah what
is it like when you want something too
much
the thing you want doesn't want you back
it's like the what's the biological
basis for that like
if you want me i don't want you back
yeah that game the french have an
expression i never i'm going to bungle
it something about
one person kisses that i can't remember
i'm not even going to try whatever you
chase you chase away yeah right
definitely
well you know that goes back now we're
getting into the art of seduction do you
want me to segue into that no i didn't
finish with my power no how dare you
interrupt yourself or let me interrupt
you okay
anyway
so we have to learn to be indirect right
we have to learn as
children we learn that if we try too
hard to get our parents attention or get
them to buy us this thing or whatever
you know we'll be punished for it we
won't get what we want so we learn all
of these kind of clever games and all
these little manipulations that all of
us play i include all of us in that
so in the world today
with with social media with all the
insane sensitivity people have to any
kind of just this
whiff of unfairness right makes people
go ballistic
you have to be especially careful with
your kind of plays for power in this
world right you have to be very delicate
and very seductive
i can't remember what your original
question is because we've gotten so
sidetracked but how can you be seductive
it because so much of your i need to
write notes down somewhere here we'll
take
um
uh here's a pen from the madonna inn my
favorite hotel oh yes which room were
you in um well i was in the nautical
room this time i wanted to be in the
horse room
oh
you should try the leprechaun room with
your leprechaun room that's my favorite
i don't know emily we went and emily got
very drunk and
and
decided that someone said something
homophobic and she let it let him have
it
and i love that about her yeah she's not
in front of the good guests
she stopped for
[Laughter]
um
madonna in power rewind to
seduction how do you stay like you know
because look as someone that has studied
the art of seduction and read it
backwards forwards understands it
the game of being present and absent and
creating this tension and playing peak
based on peekaboo
with social media you can't control how
much they see you there's an algorithm
you don't know when they're gonna check
their phone you you can't control how
exposed you are you can be overexposed
by accident because they go to your page
and they they they overdose on you
you know uh i don't know if i completely
agree with you this one time what
how dare you
whoa
so i was
you know um
do you know the the rapper sweetie i do
yeah so i was on her show and we were
talking about this very issue because
she has that problem she says robert i
read the art of seduction but how do i
create mystery because it's all about
being in people's faces and i say you
have to be able to pull back you have to
be able to sometimes be absent and make
and tease people with an idea and say or
disappear for a week beyonce does it
very well yes exactly you know michael
jackson was kind of um
he disappeared very yes but he
hard
yeah but he also knew how to do that
with his music as well he would he would
space it he wouldn't appear
he would he would space like several
years between his concerts he would
create a lot of mystery around yeah it's
harder in the era of social media but
it's still it's an art and you have you
can easily you know master this they can
access you when they want to
yeah but you could if you're not
accessible if you don't post something
or if you create something that teases
them that doesn't say exactly where you
are or what you're doing you create some
mystery you create some ambiguity
so there's still you know maybe the art
of seduction needs to be rewritten for
the media age but there's still ways to
tease people there's still ways to
create that bit of mystery and to create
absence it's not going to be literally
absent it's not going to be like there's
no picture of whitney on my instagram
account no but you're going to do
something that like goes what is whitney
up to
i'm not really sure what she keeps going
back it's the same photos she has it up
you know i the same
she hasn't uploaded a new thing or what
yeah donald glover childish gambino does
this very well beyonce does this very
okay well there you go you answered my
question thank you
honestly well you i i feel like you you
trained me you my brain is my mother
a nightmare
um
so
oh god i have so much to talk to you
about
theranose what their nose
oh katie whatever her name um
holmes holmes yeah
huh elizabeth elizabeth elizabeth
can we talk about her for a second
did i say that she managed to
did she read all your books
do you think i have no idea i have
absolutely no idea interesting how did
elizabeth holmes do this okay
she managed to con these people
do you believe
gun to your head
well i mean i would put my head between
um
that she was lying to herself
and thought it was all gonna happen and
she was like if there's a will there's a
way i'm manifesting like did because
i've done that i've done fake it till
you make it well we don't do that and it
works sometimes yeah you know
it's kind of a bit like bernie madoff in
a way
did he actually believe that he was
going to get away with it didn't he know
it was all going to collapse at some
point or did he not know the internet
was on the way he because if bernie
madoff was like 20 years earlier he
probably could have pulled it off
i don't know about that people couldn't
cooper corroborate like with email and
and stuff maybe i don't know i don't i
don't know about enough about that
but um
you know self-deception is a very
powerful thing and i think
uh
people who are really good liars and
there are lots of people who are really
good liars and i'm very fascinated by
them
are also very good at lying to
themselves
because
and i've experienced it myself when i've
lied believe me i have lied to myself i
do um okay when you feel like you're not
really quite sure whether you're lying
you actually believe the story that
you've created about yourself
you do it with so much more conviction
so to be able for elizabeth holmes to to
con so many people and so many very
powerful people
she had to believe some of it otherwise
it wouldn't have come people wouldn't
have been convinced she had to carry it
with enough conviction that i'm sure to
some extent she was deceiving herself
and probably she was thinking i don't
know she was thinking somewhere along
the way i'm going to make this real it's
going to become substantial but in the
beginning i need to fake it i need to
kind of con people
here's the thing this is fascinating
because
she
also i'm obsessed with the wisdom you
can only that only comes with age
that you can only glean with age
i
just had this epiphany like this year
where i'm like there is no way i could
have understood that on a cellular level
unless i was this old
right like i've you know i've just had
some tension in relationships because of
an age gap and my thing is i don't want
to be ageist i believe that someone
who's 20 can know more than me i believe
something that's 80 knows more than me
but you know what wisdom
can be taught and what can't like
there's certain things that come with
experience and certain things
you know when someone's in a toxic
relationship and you see it you know
what it is you're like that's love
addiction that's toxic
she's a codependent he's a mole
narcissist he's a codependent she's a
malignant narcissist he's recreating her
childhood circumstances she's that's his
mom you know exactly what it is you can
diagnose it you see it i know exactly
how this started i know how it's gonna
end it's amazing sex it's oxytocin
phenylethylamine
whatever it's pronounced
but you can't say anything there's noth
they have to walk through it themselves
they have to walk through it
and no one's ever walked up to someone
and been like hey you're in a toxic
relationship like i'm telling you this
isn't gonna end they're they're just
gonna push you away because they're in
an act of addiction
so
like what are the things
because i
have done so much work i'm 39 i've read
all these books i've been in alan on
like what are the things
that are like
you know what
you might not even be able to implement
this yet or how do we implement it
before we're ready how do we like skip
the step of experience how do we skip
the step of time
well you can't really skip it but what
you can do do you have a time machine
do i have a timer this is what i'm
asking
no i don't i'm sorry
it's on my list i'll try to make that my
next book i don't have i'm actually very
interested in the notion of time and how
we can skip around in time i'm writing
about that right now but that's not
really your question
um
so you know experience teaches it right
so i had my own weird thing myself where
um i write in in the laws of human
nature the last chapter is about how you
deal with your mortality and the idea
that you're going to die
and i wrote i thought about it very
deeply and i wrote about it
and i came up with ideas that i thought
were interesting and then three months
later i had my stroke and i you know
came this close to dying myself
and
it wasn't the same thing writing about
it in this sort of intellectual abstract
way
feeling it and experiencing it is on a
whole other level
but what i can say is if you plant the
seed in people's head with knowledge
because there are most of us walk around
kind of ignorant we don't know anything
we're walking around blind and i was
that way when i was 21 22 believe me
we don't really know what things but if
we've read something beforehand
like you know ideas in my book or other
books
a seed is planted in the brain and if
you're somewhat a self-aware person
because some people aren't some people
are
when you have that experience when you
get in that toxic relationship a little
bell will start ringing and you'll be
able to carve out
this much distance from it
and that much distance is almost
the critical with what's what's so much
important because now you'll be able to
step back and go
maybe this isn't working maybe this is a
pattern in my life the moment you do
that you've created this too much
distance and a few days later you can
make it larger and larger so if you've
read books or if you've gone to therapy
and people have planted seeds in your
brain when the experience comes up you
now have a context a framework for the
trauma because a lot of times when
traumas happen there's no context you
don't know how to deal with it you don't
you've never experienced it before
what's going on here but if you've read
something beforehand if someone's told
you certain things about life and given
you an idea about it people with more
experience
you know because i read a lot of books
when i was younger
and suddenly when i'm in the work world
and i'm 23 and i'm making all of these
stupid mistakes the ideas from books
come back to me later on and they kind
of help me deal with it so i think
that's the value i can't create a time
machine i can't make you wise beyond
your years i can't give you that
experience because experience is the
most important thing because we're
emotional animals right we're not
rational thinking creatures we're
emotional and when you're in taught in
that relationship you know that's what
that's what's happening you're not
thinking about it at all you have no
distance you have no detachment but you
can
sort of learn the ability to detach
yourself slowly i think by reading
things by creating some awareness in
your brain
it's like it's like that's so fast it's
it's like um
hoarding
information that you don't need right
now it's hoarding it's like i i just i'm
such a visual person it's like getting
all the stuff at the grocery store like
i don't even need anchovies but you
might need them in 10 years like i know
this book might not
i know you're not running a company
right now i know you're not in running
you know for office right now but you're
going to put this in your brain you're
going to program it and in 10 years
you'll be like oh
i just saved myself five years of
learning the hard way yeah and also i
i'd play that time game in mastery um
because i'm really writing that book for
what are you looking for no i was just
like i was just because masteries yeah
here because this book is really kind of
the
you've said this so many times i don't
want to make you say it again you've
sort of distilled everything kind of
into one book it's kind of like a
fruitcake in a way
it's got everything in it and everyone
should get it for christmas
exactly perfect
um
so in mastery i'm kind of playing this
weird time game because
the book is intended for people who are
22 who are just leaving college and are
trying to figure out what they're
supposed to do in life
but i'm enticing you and i'm planting
the seed of
10 years down the road this is what
you're going to is going to happen to
you when your brain reaches a certain
level and you've made so many
connections you've learned so many
things you're going to become immensely
creative and then you're going to become
intuitive with your knowledge and i'm
kind of teasing you saying
if you stick with this long enough
that knowledge will then burst into
creativity into this kind of mastery of
the subject and so i'm kind of luring
you into the future and then
10 years later when you have reached
that point you will remember what i
wrote about in the book
oh my god i'm looking at all my
questions
yeah they're so stupid can a german ever
be in power again
is that really your question oh no i
don't know that's a good question this
was just me like on the plane just being
like is it jerk well no because i was
thinking like
you know that question
because how much of of you know
the the
how much you know i'm obsessed with the
ancestral trauma and the way we have to
account for
history and what we do now and like
you know this is going to be
controversial that's my brand but
when
who
you know when you were talking about um
sort of like individualism you know
singular versus the community or or
wanting to be individual versus the mass
like it made me think about the cultural
differences just when i'm touring
between like america scandinavia and
then asia wow that's interesting yeah
where it's like in scandinavia i went
and there's the idea of a hierarchy is
is looked down upon completely the boss
dresses the same as they don't even have
first class in their airplanes they
don't the idea of a class system is very
looked down upon you don't you walk into
a office you don't know who the boss is
whereas you walk you walk in an office
in america and you you can whoever has
the biggest office the nicest shoes the
nicest car like that must be the alpha
that must be the person in charge and
then in asia um assimilating and being
similar we all have the same gucci shoes
we all have the same you know fendi bag
like that is valued
um so
there was i was just sort of thinking
like
that i should have written this question
out more clearly is what i was
definitely thinking
um but i was wondering is there any
area of the world that's more
predisposed
to be
for
that's
right now because it's probably going to
be based on when in time you know
because i'm sure
i'm sure certain areas get more
fashionable and
it comes in waves and the vicissitudes
of like now russia gets to
you know come back in to being in charge
and
like it's not being russian right now
it's like a little bit
like we see you
we don't trust you
is there anything ancestral about
power that benefits you
does anyone have a head start
well um i don't know if i'm that smart
appeal to answer that question because
it's a pretty complicated one but i
would say
that italians
so italy is the land of machiavelli
right
machiavelli is the great writer of the
prince wrote about power kind of my
patron saint in a way sylvia berlusconi
yes
so
i've dealt with italians since then and
i went on an incredible book tour soon
after the 48 laws of power came out
and i worked there briefly in the mid
90s
it is still a very machiavellian place
right and when i wrote the 48 laws of
power they instantly got it they were so
excited about it because it's in their
blood there's something very deeply
machiavellian about the culture and i
don't mean anything negative about it
because i don't think there's anything
negative about the word machiavellian
but it goes back hundreds and hundreds
of years
and so i also think there are cultures
that have that in them there are
cultures in the middle east
that are very machiavellian i can tell
by the way certain places react to my
book
so the scandinavians
they're not into them no no no no no no
no it's tacky
the french kind of are but not they're
sort of a little bit they don't like
americans they're kind of into it the
germans they're too frightened of it
because there's
because that's we we
already had someone manipulate everybody
for
untoward reasons but the russians they
love it they're fascinated by it
certain shameless certain arab countries
they love it they're fascinated by it
you know i did some consulting work in
the middle east
and the political situation there
is totally is like a page pages out of
the 48 laws of power
you know they're playing intense
3d chess power games there so there are
cultures where that kind of
sense of power and the kind of the
primal game of power in its brute sense
is very much a part of their culture
america is different america's we've got
a puritan or ancestry we're kind of you
know garvidil had a great quote
we're the most powerful country in the
world but we want to believe that our
politicians are all motivated by
morality we don't want to think of
ourselves as a power hungry cult country
even though we are so immensely powerful
so we're kind of two-faced about a bit
hypocritical
so to answer your question if i am
because i'm rambling now myself how dare
you is
your rambles are more coherent than most
people's
written speeches is that there is a
cultural element to this i i truly
believe a culture has a certain
relationship to power a comfort with it
an excitement in it or a kind of a fear
or a kind of a
a repulsion towards it or whatever
and so you know and these things
go back hundreds of years
and of course they evolve they change so
the germans who the germans of the 1930s
aren't the germans of who are now
is there something about the sorry to um
get into stereotypes here but
german with what happened in german the
history of germany there is a very
specific sexual
scene in germany is there the you know
more about this than i do maybe i don't
know anything or maybe it's just more
like you know the same way people are
like aren't all comedians like crazy
mentally ill it's like
i just we're the ones that advertise it
the most so you're gonna think that more
of us do but we're just the way you know
your local ups drivers probably not like
i'm bipolar you know it's so
um maybe germans just
it's there's less shame involved but
there's like a big s m sex dom club
scene yeah a lot of like power
wow stuff i was just
curious if that was
a thing
i don't have any first-hand experience i
was curious if you have a phone number
to it
no but it makes sense that a lot of
their movies have to deal with that
there's there is a kind of so like shame
and being degraded and being humiliated
and i'm just so and that's obviously
goes
sexual sometimes but there's something
fascinating about why is this piece of
land in the middle of this other land
so different than the other lands with
the fence around it all of a sudden
people want to be degraded in that exact
spot or
wear leather and gags and fish hooks and
it's just wild to me
well there's a bit of a generalization i
don't know how widespread it is but you
know more than i obviously i do i'm
training to be a dominator so i'm just
feeling out just putting feelers out to
see if there's any any bites see if i'm
getting any bites but there is a there
is a weird relationship to power and
there is something very kind of sexual
a sexual undercurrent to the whole
notion of power
and our our desires our sexual desires
are intermixed with desires for power as
well but i just was like trying to make
some connection because you know
comedians we don't we're not historians
we're not geniuses like you and
brilliant writers but we try to make
stupid connections that's every now and
then
um like like closing your eyes and
throwing a dart of like
you know germany like there's all this
sexual
degradation there of like your pieces
you know you just lost your whole german
audience
but it's a big thing there's an
instagram feed that is only people in
germany
walking guys walking other guys on
leashes and grocery stores as dogs they
walk they walk them through stores to
humil publicly humiliate them and i'm
like oh is this like some weird thing
with the holocaust of some shame of like
embarrassment of like to sort of like
the pendulum swung and now they need to
like you know publicly humiliate
themselves after you know being so
ashamed or you know i just i i i'm
always trying to like put weird little
equations like that together
um
you brought up italy
fascinating i need to talk about the
mafia i didn't plan on it
how
does the mafia
manage
to keep everybody
quiet
how do you get someone to not
in this day and age
like how
i can't really say i'm too afraid truly
yeah
um but but like what but
can we talk about why you're afraid
no i was just kidding
but i mean there was because i did i
narrated the bunga bunga podcast for
wondering that was about silvio
berlusconi so i learned a lot about him
because of that and i didn't i didn't
know that much about him you know now i
know it's like oh that was like the
blueprint for trump and and putin and
like
i just like i'm fascinated by one guy
who's like oh i remember you were i
remember this berlusconi fascination
yeah just the idea that's that
everyone's like
dada okay because do we all just turn
five years old like how do you
manipulate that many people
and we were just talking about
succession earlier like you know about
how to
collude and not how do you get
you know i mean to get four people to
you know not gossip about you when you
leave the room much less getting people
to be like we're gonna kill this person
i need
900 people to keep it a secret in the
day of like twitter and texting
yeah i don't know i mean uh obviously
fear plays a very large role in it and
the fear is is very real it's bad family
it being family very family oriented
very patriarchal guilt shame you owe me
yeah that's true they've been programmed
from birth yeah that's true
and it's very real people are being
killed for divulging their secrets and
that will that's very powerful
how does the mafia still kill people and
nobody knows
arthur i don't know much about the mafia
i don't i don't like scientology in the
mafia i'm just like obsessed with
scientology for sure yeah how do you do
like today
how is no one just screen gra how is
there not like some assistant or intern
who just screen grabs and it's like this
is a scam
how is that just not like on twitter
well you know
i was um i had a weird feeling last
night just to make this just to bring it
back down to that
um i was on a radio show
there was an am radio show that still
exists right
late at night
and i was listen and there were callers
in
and i was getting this feeling about our
country that i never really had before
but it's also the world
that there are a lot of people right now
who are kind of in pain that are very
lonely that don't know where they're
going they're not getting anything in
life that means anything to them
because in so many ways the culture
doesn't really give them anything
to feed on that's substantial right
and so
when you have large groups of people
that are kind of disconnected and
alienated they don't really
feel like there's a purpose to their
life and they're kind of anxious which
is part of how hitler yeah pounced yeah
and capitalized on that very
right all you need is a charismatic
leader who kind of feeds on that and
says i'm going to give you i'm going to
supply what's missing in your life
right and if you live in a culture like
in italy or germany where there is the
family and there are these kind of
things relationships to authority that
can be very powerful but we still have
that in our country as well
so
when you have large groups of people who
feel kind of empty and there's no
connection in their life between
the power politics and what's going on
with them they're searching for
something and if you give them a cause
to believe in a party to believe in some
ideology they're going to grab on to it
right make them feel important essential
yeah and also
i talk in laws of human nature about our
dark side and we all have these kind of
dark impulses these kind of aggressive
impulses where we want to act out but
we're too afraid to do that
when you have like this kind of
charismatic
like leader like a hitler or somebody
like that it gives you license now
suddenly to act out all those darker
impulses that you've been repressing
right
i have a weird question
if you i'm not into bondage
well you're on this podcast it's
basically the same thing you're trapped
here
if you had to kill someone how would you
do it
as someone that has just studied every
psychopath and like well what are the
circumstances it's something you just
have to kill someone like you gotta get
rid of someone
they're
harming your your anna they're they're
it's just they gotta go and you're not
gonna go to jail you're not gonna get in
trouble
i had a gun i'd shoot them you just
shoot them in the face why not
yeah that makes sense and shoot them in
the heart
or the head yeah that makes sense let me
ask you
so let's say why did you ask that
question i don't know i was just
thinking about the dark i mean a more
interesting question is like how would
you commit suicide
that's the better question of course of
course you're better at this than me um
that's a really good question
i think about that i don't know how
you'd commit suicide
i probably
i would never jump i watched that that
um the trailer for the one about the san
francisco
the jumping off the golden gate bridge
and it was i could not
have there was it was a someone put a
camera because how many people commit
suicide on the golden gate bridge every
year
quite a few 20 or 30. 20 or 30 people a
year but they they put a live camera on
it like a gopro or something
and um
they watch the people like deliberate
you know so you see the footage of them
pacing back and forth and making the
decision and making phone calls oh my
god
you're seeing the moments and sometimes
hours and days before
and then you see them jump and there's
this one guy
i don't
please tell me if i'm misremembering
this
um
that uh
he survived they interviewed him oh
that's amazing that's a fascinating
story because i'm obsessed with when you
jump what's going through your mind well
there's a lot of literature on that
because there's no one that's really
there to survive to tell the tale who
can well there are people who survive
from incredible falls well i want to
hear this from you but he said that he
was instantly regretted
oh really and then apparently he landed
on a seal and bounced off the seal no
and survived
is this a dream what happened to this
what happened to what happened to the
seal brought to you by sea world i am
now sponsored by the
most evil corporation on the planet um
what happened to the seal
i don't know that's a great question i
don't think the seal wanted to be
involved um
this is a pixar movie waiting
me at pixar hey so this guy committed
suicide but a seal saves his life
this is the next finding nemo you guys
but the seal dies in the process
yeah 20 years ago kevin hines jumped off
the golden gate bridge as he was falling
he realized he didn't want to die and he
didn't
they made a documentary about it
he
he was drowning when he jumped and it
hadn't been for the sea lion that was
circling beneath me and kept me afloat
until the coast guard was behind me i
would not be here
so you didn't land on the sea lion but
that's more interesting
you're like like balances on this i mean
that it's okay yeah of course i turned
it into like boy
i turned into the sea lion being like i
got you buddy i got you like i'm
picturing mo and i'm being like don't
worry
but um
but what when people fall do they
instantly regret it
um
some people do i don't know i don't
haven't really read about that but i
know that there's a whole phenomenon of
your life flashing before you and it's
very real and a lot of people report
that
and some people report incredible
feelings i'm going to do that just to
remember what my life what happened in
my life
but then it might be the last moment of
yourself
isn't it weird to think i oh
it's so weird to i was uh david sinclair
posted today something about a place in
greece or italy or somewhere where they
live to 107
i guess everybody yeah or uh the average
age i was just looking it up
do you want to live 207 i don't think so
i don't think so wait that would be 68
more years of twitter on my home screen
i did not
oh well twitter's not on my home screen
anymore so
so is twitter over twitter twitter's
cancelled if i don't have it on my app
it must be gone for for good
um
but
i okay i want to talk to you about hi
like gut instincts and hiring like
you know i think a lot of people
listening a lot of people that are like
looking up to you now and even like the
younger people that are just coming out
of college and discovering you that want
to start their businesses and take over
the world like
what
at a time where
power kind of puts a target on your back
you know like because now you're being
if you're in power you're now being
hunted
it's like let me find that tweet from 20
years ago let me talk to that
ex-girlfriend or ex-boyfriend from 20
let me talk to that landlord
you're making me scared i know trust me
but is there
like
you know anything to be said about is is
the
you know
in terms of having skeletons in your
closet how about that
you know like i was thinking about you
today because i guess
i know i know uh oh i hate talking about
politics i never do but i'm just gonna
do it for this example when you show any
kind of weakness like i've learned from
your books like you don't want to show
weakness in any ways but unless it's
strategic
but
like biden farted at a thing he did what
oh my gosh robert
that should be headline news
camilla and camilla parker bowles won't
stop talking about it i think i did her
hear about this okay so this is like
it's a whole thing he farted at some
conference what is it pat
joe barton
farts
on live
joe biden's
loud fart sound interrupts live chat
with pennsylvania governor tom wolf
okay
and then donald trump jr shares it on
twitter apparently it's like pretty wild
and now
uh okay president biden okay let's make
sure there's a real website
um and not like alexjones.com
uh
uh farted in front of camilla parker
bowles at the climate summit in glasgow
last week and she
[Music]
so like is this a power move okay
[Laughter]
that is the 49th law of power
fart
like when you become the president fart
like that is the biggest
power move well lbj when he was
president
to kind of show that he was the boss and
he could do anything and his
subordinates were like nothing he would
he would have them come to the office
and he'd be on the toilet taking a dump
and he'd have them like sit there and
take notes
and just jesus to put them in their
place
read rob o'carroll's book it's all true
did you ever see um this i might need to
share my screen for did you ever see
when whoopi goldberg farted on the view
what no i never said emily stop this
can you can we share my screen so that i
can show this
oh no okay this is i am not to leave the
room because this is this this
i'm gonna have to leave the room too i
think there was a clip of donald trump
farting wasn't there oh yeah there was
he wait wait hold on it's also by the
way
claire danes is talking about
9 11. oh please
stop it i don't want to see it i want
this how do i get the ball to make me
explode i think it explores that in a
really smart way
you're so nice oh excuse me
that just blew a little frog out of
there
i mean that to me the fact that she was
just like what
the the the word whoopee would be
cushion like what so sad i when i
it's claire danes is talking about 9 11.
no stop it this is painful
that's like my worst that's going to
happen to me at some point that's my
destiny
we now take a break in me fawning over
robert greene
my just
big daddy energy
i just love him so much am i flirting
too much with him no he's so
he liked me which i'm now feeling better
about myself as a human because he likes
he by the way you should yeah
that's like i passed a pretty big best
big actually yeah he's kind of the only
person's approval i need at this point
and he was like at the end of the show
he was like i'm very impressed with you
and i was like
he doesn't
do that yeah i mean he didn't say it but
i felt that oh he didn't say so you just
lied
he said something that wasn't true
you said he said it though
which is weird he said it with his
actions that's not he said it with his
actions and he said it with but he said
i googled things really fast so he was
impressed by that well he's he's older i
mean
it's
no one else has said that no one said
that under 40.
because i have to
like i have to look at you and then try
to go like we should google that and
then you don't and then i have to be
like hey em can we look that up and then
anywhere did i stop playing snood any
roadblock
will will be an obstacle that you'll
give up i'll be like google is a dora
duncan and it'll be like i don't know
how to spell it i that is not true i
just ah why do we talk about isadora
duncan so much on this podcast because
she hung herself on a scarf i wish
and you know what had she got it at
stitch fix maybe she wouldn't have been
in that jam and damn you're good
you know she bought it herself
you shouldn't be buying scarves for
yourself it was too long yeah she didn't
use stitch fix freestyle the number one
trusted style destination where you can
discover and instantly buy curated items
based on your styles likes
never sent you a scarf so long that it
would get stuck in a wheel of a
convertible in the 40s
okay they've got styles for workouts
work wear lounging around the house or
for a night out on the town stitch fix
has clothes for any occasion and takes
the the hassle off your plate there's no
subscription required free shipping
returns in exchanges i benton took my
test for me because you take a quiz
benton took my test from me and benton
finally did something that was not
big sabotage energy and the clothes i am
getting honestly i've worn them uh on
most of the shows on the tour
uh i wore the
freaking cutest pants we have a video of
me putting them on
the tops are so cute and i finally don't
look like a lesbian lumberjack at shows
i've grown up and stitch fix has like
changed my look and the shows are
getting so much now that i dress like a
like very hip adult i don't get as many
heckles you dress for the job you want
which is why i'm wearing a librarian's
cardigan
yeah which is why you're dressed like a
martha oh look at this oh this is a full
stitch fix wardrobe you're a stitcher
i'm such a stitcher you're a snitcher
but i feel like this is
like i can do it this is so much better
than jeans what are these pants how do
they know i know it looks like you
should be in a theater now
wow
don't you think just a little pretty
with the backdrop
and then i can wear this
top from stitch fix
tomorrow for
green bay it's green cute oh yeah that's
really smart
people are gonna love that and it's
still wild like you look at these
pockets these are actual pockets real
pockets for a real life woman wow this
is so good don't you think yeah everyone
should go to stitchfix.com sold out tour
look am i i'm really stepping it up with
my looks at the contour thank you stitch
fix we're not i'm not wearing pajamas
anymore as a comedian i'm an adult
fashionable adult thank you stitch fix
tell them thank you thank you stitch fix
i'm proud to be a stitcher and i'm sorry
benton's a stitcher we're snitching on
stitch picks yeah cause everybody should
know everyone everyone's nobody bbe get
started today by filling out your style
quiz at stitchfix.com
whitney don't worry you can't fail this
quiz that's
stitchfix.comwhitney to try stitch fix
freestyle stitchfix.com
don't dress like a martha dress like a
whitney
houston in a bathtub
uh
so i've been on the road with benton we
have done and emily too emily's coming
first sometimes emily doesn't come and i
just it's just me and uh if i know
you're flying spirit i don't think
it's just me in a cage with a tiger all
weekend uh and you guys haven't killed
each other yet no no uh and uh but
benton in the mornings he likes to chat
so
i need a distraction i need a
therapeutic game to play you need a
break from your best fiend just exactly
right
i've been talking to you for like 15
minutes what are you doing
[Music]
avoiding you at all costs well it's
really hard to do when you're you know
laying on the ground by me so what are
you doing i'm doing something way more
fun than talking to you okay
oh you're playing best fiends
like i'm getting i'm really getting good
at this
[Music]
come in
unique gameplay best fiends has it all
an amazing storyline collectible fiends
and tons of fun puzzles i can't put it
down as you just saw and i also play it
lying down because my l4 has really took
a hit in green bay
uh you can play it anywhere even if you
don't have wi-fi
not a problem play best fiends wherever
and whenever you want with offline mode
so even if your holiday travels take you
off the beaten path uh you can still
play best fiends uh download best fiends
free today on the app store or google
play it's friends but without the r best
fiends
and now back to someone i to hear talk
robert greene
a friend of mine the other day was
talking about hiring like an assistant
okay all right
and now we're back tonight calm down
back to normal adult conversations sorry
i know robert green
famous robert greene is on i'm talking
about flatulence
um
but but it's more about weakness to me
like what to showing weakness showing
vulnerabilities because it's like now
okay women are in power
more now
like right and
i don't want to be stoic and i want to
be able to share my vulnerabilities and
part of what my job is is to over share
and show my vulnerabilities and embed
them and there's a certain strength in
that
uh oh you're writing no is that your
suicide note no it's been ready
and um
there is a thing and i don't know i
don't know how to say this so i'm just
gonna say it i was talking to a friend
of mine who's getting a little bit of
success and she's like i'm gonna hire an
assistant okay and i was like well
if you're gonna hire i wouldn't look at
it that way
hire a teammate tell me if any of this
logic is is broken
you know i think that
because you said the word subordinate
earlier it's like i did well no it was
like it was just no with with like hit
your subordinates like hitler your
subordinates or whatever you know what i
mean it's like you want someone because
you're
the person that was your reach research
assistant right is now
a brilliant writer yes his name ryan
holliday ryan hi famous than i am yeah
so but you were like
um
don't outshine the master but uh
you
don't hire someone that's gonna run your
errand that's not what they you want
someone that's a star that's gonna be
your teammate
what what's happening with your face you
hate me no i just don't agree with you
but hold on
i'm not saying it well okay i'm not
saying it well
so i think the days of wanting someone
to do something for you or needing power
over someone
is in the day of postmates and amazon
and yeah yeah that's true you can book
your own flight let you know
you're not um i'm trying to avoid saying
the word slave is basically what's
happening right now so i'm just um tap
dancing but it's just like the idea of
there's so many ways
i think there's so much power in doing
some things yourself yes and having
anyone that is in your life be
my goal is always
you're on this team so that one day i
work for you you bring something i don't
have
definitely and i'm investing in you and
um
i don't want to be above you i want i
want you to event
what you hate me
well the parts of it i agree with you
and parts i don't agree with you okay
well there's that's why we're so similar
i disagree with me all the time okay
um
well you know there is such a thing as
somebody having more experience than
another person and there is such a thing
as somebody who's a bit has authority
over you
and not everything has to be fair and
equal no
so you're the you're the boss
you make more money you have more
experience you know the business and
that's been earned and it's been earned
now you're hiring someone yes they are
not your s word okay i agree
um and they you do want them to feel
like they're a part of the team right
but you also want them to feel that
they're going to learn something from if
there's a level of respect of course
respect has to be there but i don't want
someone that's just you you always make
me think of octopuses like just a
mindless like you want someone who's
going to sort of
challenge you and who's really in their
own way they're investing okay okay but
let me give you an example of a weak
example from my own life because that's
easy oh ramona
um so i i need a researcher right
careful sorry mona is made of sticks and
she just knocked over my cane that's all
right sorry no no she's like lean on me
um so i need to hire a research
assistant because i'm not getting
younger and i need help but i've tried
this with every one of my books
so i hired this person let's just call
him or her ex
right
and him or her i'll just use the
pronoun they okay
is
very smart
has degrees
is you know very academic
very knowledgeable
and i'm looking for someone like you who
i like you said who i can train who will
then be able to bring some things that i
can't get right and i like hiring young
people because they know things about
the internet that i that i don't and
they can help me organize my life and
they they're smarter about those kinds
of things
but the problem with this person x
was that they had an ego and they
thought that they were
almost as as good as i am and so like i
give this person you know some a chapter
that i wrote just expecting him to say
robert it's brilliant i love it
and he or she comes back and says you
know here are things that i would change
and hear things that were edited you
didn't earn that right my friend and i
fired him right then and there
i could see right there and there that
he had this ego that he was and now i've
revealed that it's a man
he was kind of pushing you know he he he
wanted he wanted the attention he wanted
to be thought of that he was brilliant
and you had to bide your time you have
to know that you're an apprentice and an
apprentice learns from somebody who has
more experience yes you have things to
offer i'm very respectful i listen i
listen to your ideas i know that there's
a back and forth here but at a certain
point
one person is the boss one person has
experience and you're learning from them
and there has to be a degree of respect
and some degree of distance
right and hierarchy for order i think so
a little bit maybe i'm just too
old-fashioned that way there's something
to be said for
order and clarity especially when you're
dealing with a lot of people directing a
movie running a tv show running a
business ever you know there's a lot of
people that you know i know they're like
i want to start this company i want to
direct this movie i want to write a tv
show i want to be a famous comedian i'm
going to do this this it's like well you
have to be comfortable
with
what might seem like an archaic or not
progressive hierarchy system so that
some
if you're
if you imagine a plane there can't be
nine hands on one plane there's one
person and they're like you guys get out
of the way i know what i'm doing
and i'm gonna do this and you guys need
to trust me
that leads me to a question of can you
teach instinct
people with good instincts how do you
know if someone has a good good ins
because to me that's the most valuable
thing in a person is does someone have
good instincts like
people can make mistakes and they can
mess up honest honest mistakes are
totally fine i i think honest mistakes
are actually kind of uh
a little bit delightful because the way
people
handle them yeah says a lot about their
character yeah of saying oh i forgot
about that i'm sorry and they'll tell
you the truth and you're like oh great
you told me the truth like that was an
honest mistake i like you more now kind
of you know because now i can trust you
but
can you teach someone's instinct i think
about power and i think about okay once
you get power you know you've read all
of our green's books you and it's helped
you get the you know relationship you
want or
the job you want or the company that you
wanted to build and now it's about
how what who do i keep who do i not keep
who do i break up with who do i stay
with who i you know
and there's a lot of i've lost a lot of
time trying to train people to think a
certain way whether it's boyfriends
you know it works very well with animals
actually which is why i love animals so
much because it sticks um
but
there's a certain point where you gotta
surrender and just go like
the instinct is what matters more than
the on a daily basis like training
someone to do this right do you know
what i'm saying well i do um i i look at
it a little bit differently
um i sort of look at people's character
as what matters
right so we see the surface of people
they smile a lot they're very charming
they please they say whitney i think
you're hilarious i love you etc but we
really don't know what's going on
beneath the mask yeah
and we hire them based on how charming
they are based on the resume based on
all the appearances based on our
insecurities we hire them to yeah we
project onto them what we think they are
which isn't the reality and we're not
seeing inside them
and so i say that people have a
character that's deeply deeply engraved
and it's something that they can't
almost control
it comes from it's partially genetic
and it's partially from their early
attachments etc
right and so there are people with a
strong character and people with a
strong character usually have the right
instincts i think
and a strong character is someone who
has
a sort of elastic ego
they don't get immediately defensive
if you criticize them
and you say i want you to be more like
this they don't get inwardly resentful
they don't kind of
try to betray you or sabotage you later
on or work against you that you know
they don't they don't um
they don't take it the wrong way
right they take it constructively so
their ego can kind of bend a little bit
with the circumstance
people with a strong character can stand
pressure and stress so if things get
stressful they don't crumble and become
a whiny little baby they kind of can can
stay firm and kind of help you in a
stressful moment they can be the one
kind of
you know giving you strength etc
and and a person with strong character
can work in a team they can work with
other people they don't have to have
everything be about them yeah yeah yeah
yeah so that kind of person is the kind
of person you want to hire and the kind
of person you want around you
more than more than where they went to
school more than how charming they are
because when situations get tough and
you need to depend on them
they're going to be able to to give you
what you want you know and i do think
that people who have that kind of
character generally have the right kind
of instincts in certain situations hmm
what do you think in terms of this you
know um
so let's just say one more thing please
um you know a lot of times when we meet
a person
we can sense right away that there's
something wrong about them
right
and i tell people who get into toxic
relationships
you know can you go back to that moment
when you first met them
and can you remember a moment
where you got initially a little bit
uncomfortable in their presence or
conflated discomfort with butterflies
passion yeah but you didn't trust the
feelings that's what i'm getting at
right
so a lot of people have the right
instincts because we are animals and we
can kind of feel that a person is fake
or that a person is hiding something
you know like children are very good at
that they can sense that someone is fake
or they're hiding yeah full of shit um
and we have it too to some degree but we
don't trust our instincts so that's the
other problem we're all sort of sensing
that something is wrong but we we're
kind of we've learned to like not trust
these kind of feelings and instincts and
it's it is sometimes i hate to bring
gender into it but like
i think women more so you're crazy
you're psycho you're judgmental you're
critical you're gossiping you know when
you have a gut instinct i just don't
trust that person it was just because
she's pretty no i i have a gut feeling
well she's prettier than you that's why
you don't like her no i i just have a
weird feeling about this person and then
we're taught to deny our instincts yeah
you know
you're too emotional you're saying that
women have better instincts or more
sharper than men they're sharper but
also we're taught to minimize them and
quell them faster because we're crazy
we're emotional we're sensitive or
psycho or you know jealous you're being
jealous we're taught to
not listen to them and over pathologize
our reaction definitely definitely think
of how many relationships and how many
traumas that would save you if you had
trusted your instincts in that first
moment when you met this person and you
kind of got overwhelmed you for a second
you felt uncomfortable in their presence
something in their eyes seemed a little
bit dead the smile seemed a little bit
fake
they weren't listening to you but they
were kind of looking the other way
and you felt that for about five seconds
and then you disregarded it because then
they're charming then they see something
to flatter you and then you kind of
forget that first moment where you felt
that discomfort and you never go back to
that likely
you liked the dissonance you liked the
fact that you had that's a whole other
story that's like what's going on with
you that you
saw the you know we say you know red
flag and then went what is that now now
i need to figure out how this adds up i
need to now i need to make that
equation make sense yeah like i thought
i saw am i the only person that saw that
or are we about are we soul mates i saw
that i saw him without the mask maybe he
were soul mates i'm the only person
that's ever seen that side you know what
i mean oh that's that's creepy that's
scary that's very toxic toxic yeah my
brand
yeah yeah but it's i think the lesson is
there it is to trust some of these
instincts more
to understand that they occur for a
reason and that you have a gut reaction
to people that's often very true and
very real
and occurs for a reason and you're so
obviously
if not the most articulate eloquent
person even if you can't articulate it
it doesn't mean it's not an instinct
yeah so i can go i have a
gut about this i can't
tell you i can't elegantly
lay out why this person
is not a match
maybe in five minutes or maybe in five
years i'll be able to articulate it i'm
just going to go with this gut feeling
even though i can't put words to it
we rely too much on words right
so we are animals at heart and we have
these feelings and they're very real
when they happen in the moment they
happen before the language kicks in
right
and so you've got to trust them and not
try to put it into words what
you know
sorry to go back to theranos for a
second i'm just fascinated because maybe
she's just a psychopath or a sociopath
and that's that is what it is
but
i was just thinking about mona and these
are wolves you know that she got a husky
no i didn't know that she has a husky so
elizabeth holmes got a husky she's like
i got this husky from this breeder
and then just and someone's like that
looks like a wolf or i don't know how it
the inception of this lie and then she
started telling people it was a wolf
balto she named it balto after
the
a famous like husky dog that used to
deliver medical supplies in
alaska that's right that's right that's
exactly right yeah the dropout is this
podcast about the court case which i am
on the edge of this is my o.j you need
to play elizabeth holmes don't you think
no emily actually does the most amazing
elizabeth holmes
she does the most amazing because she
has such big eyes emily
but also being blonde like the fact that
this woman was able to seduce all these
brilliant men
these henry kissinger like these
incredibly brilliant men they're the
easiest to fool
how why
well they have a blind spot they think
that they're so smart they're so old and
blind they talk about in the 48 laws of
power con artists often choose people
who are the most sophisticated so i tell
the story in the 48 laws of power of the
great con artist count victor lustig
who actually went and conned al capone
himself knowing full well that if al
capone saw saw through it he'd be in the
bottom of a river within a few days
right and he went and he conned al
capone knowing that a person like that
never thinks that anybody could ever
calm them because they're so smart
they're so together i'm the last person
anybody would try it's like the big lie
like like like why i'm going to trust
you with this insane lie
be my mom as a worm
because you wouldn't because you would
never get away with it so why would you
lie about it so i'm going to trust you
yeah why would you never get away
conning henry kissinger so the fact that
you're doing it must mean you're
trustworthy yeah yeah and she's blonde
and she's
she is she pretty okay she's pretty in a
way that is i this is my theory on and i
just want to run it by you okay she's in
a time where it was like post me too
she's the she's pretty in a way that is
masculine enough
to not be oh you're just giving her
money because she's this hot chick
you're right right right
and and feminine enough to be like oh
you're giving money to a woman right who
is blonde she's got the black turtleneck
and she's got the whole steve jobs thing
going well that was very like calculated
she wore the steve jobs thing i i as i'm
wearing a turtleneck um
but
but no uh i uh
it was like it gave you got to check off
your i'm a
man who's a feminist card i believe in
women i believe women are smart exactly
but the thing that's so funny to me
about it is like they were like she went
to stanford and she dropped out
therefore she's smarter than the ones
that went for four years
what
like an 18 year old was like i don't
need any more school
therefore she's smarter it's almost like
her
uh
like
blind egomania
was so insane that it overwhelmed their
intelligence to go oh she must be
smarter than me because she quit
stanford well there were a lot of people
who really made it in silicon valley who
have that kind of story behind them
you know bill gates dropped out of
college
there were a few others like but he
had here well my whole thing with their
nose was like the technology didn't
exist it was a very good idea
you know you can have good ideas good
ideas don't mean anything you know we
all have good ideas yeah but people
don't think that far in advance you know
a lot of it has to do
what you do in a con game because the
word con game means confidence game is
you're gaining the con is that where
khan comes from yes getting conned ooh
love that and so you're earning the
confidence of the other person
and so
the con game has to be something that
they want to believe in already
so if people are primed to believe that
there's this miracle thing that could
happen at the pharmacy they could
diagnose you then they're more prone to
like believe that you're telling the
truth right because it seems like this
magical cure that will exist well yeah i
want to get on that i mean think of it
yes sorry oh my gosh how did i just
interrupt you with my
expression
i just went
and you're like
okay well no because i have this thing
i'm sorry to bring this up again
but when a female pilot comes on the
plane
when i'm on a plane and a female pilot
walks on i'm like uh oh that's my first
reaction uh oh
i've never seen one of those that can't
be good your hair is really interesting
my hair just went crazy what happened i
kind of like it yeah
it's kind of like one of those cartoons
um fraggle rock a big energy
so and i go uh-oh and then i go wait no
um i um uh babe with the power what
power i look like one of labyrinths
gremlins david bowie's gremlins who do
you do you remind me of the babe
um
uh
and then i go wait no
because we
okay so on friday we flew spirit
airlines
and
have you ever heard of that
no it doesn't sound sketchy it's
bent as benton said benjamin the great
benjamin said um it's called spirit
because that's what you are after you
fly it after all the time
corpse airlines
and
there was a woman and uh
and i go a woman pilot oh no they're not
gonna be as good because i don't see as
many that's what your stupid sexist
brain does
and then you go wait no she had to be
twice as good to get half as far she
must be way better
so then the trick of when i see
elizabeth holmes
if she's blonde and has blue eyes and is
she must be like a super genius
because she's defied all these
stereotypes you know all the blonde dumb
blonde jokes how do you drown a blonde
put a scratch and sniff snicker on the
bottom of a pool
you know what i mean like
how do you drown a blonde
you put a scratch and sniff sticker on
the bottom of a swimming pool
like i'm thinking of just dumb blonde
jokes i don't even get the joke i'm that
stupid like it's no it's it's i'm
probably not saying it right
it's uh because then the blonde would go
down and scratch it and sniff it and
drown oh because she would be trying to
sniff it like i i don't remember dumb
blonde jokes how do you know
blonde's been using a computer
just white out there's why not on the
screen there's white out on the screen
or how do you kill a blonde or like what
do you do when a blonde throws a grenade
at you
pull the pin and throw it back
okay guys
so like just like thank you if she's
blonde and blue-eyed and pretty and
young
and she's like wants to do this she must
be
jeff zuckerberg yeah because she comes
in this packaging so she must be
triple is brilliant
yeah it would have been great to be
there to hear like her initial pitch
like what she said to people you know
and how she kind of gave them the idea
that she was
that she was so brilliant or whatever
is it just the blonde hair there must
have been something that she said well
there's i think she i mean i definitely
think she's a robert green fan she would
tell a story about her uncle
that was in a war and she or no so she
said she her uncle at alzheimer's and
she's like if he only if we only had a
blood test to catch this sooner and it
turns out she was never really that
close with him
is that at him yeah she will she i think
she lied about him having her i don't
know she lied about it but she he had
cancer but he has cancer now for sure
you're thinking of the war the war thing
was that she lied about them using
the einstein on the battlefield the
einstein
the medicine on the on so basically she
said this to henry kissinger wouldn't it
be great if in the battlefield
you know when soldiers are fighting you
could take their blood real quick and
find out what which honestly that's
weird to me because it's like no one
needs to find out if they have aids on
the battlefield
that's not what we're doing here like
it's the bloods everywhere what are you
talking about like hey i just want to
know real quick if i have sickle cell
anemia that's not what we're doing like
my type o
like there's gut there's bullets coming
in my head but it was a how do i get a
quick blood test real quick
to make sure
uh to detect cancer like at cvs
you know like can i go to cvs pick up my
thyroid medication at 48 years old and
do a little prick of blood and find out
oh my gosh yeah who wouldn't want to
want that but it's it's
you know easy bake oven you know it's
like
well you know i don't know if i told you
this story the last time i was here but
if i did please stop me because i don't
want to be like i'm getting daughtering
and i'm repeating the same stories
but i have a very interesting lesson
about that
i was 22 years old and i was and i was
in paris france
and i wanted to stay there and work
there right
and did i tell the story no but there's
some of it in this book no that's not
the story that's not the same book
because there is a couple pairs stories
in here well anyway
so i'm in paris france and i'd been
there previously for a couple for a
couple weeks and then i went to greece
and i came back i decided i want to stay
in paris and i had been in this hotel
and i was i had been in ireland before
that believe me i'm going to make this
story make sense no i did okay you're
robert
okay so i was wearing i'd been in
ireland the first time i was in person i
had this little green cap and i went to
this hotel and the owner of this hotel
said you're an irishman and i was kind
of drunk oh yes yes i'm from ireland and
i'm speaking french and i kind of put an
irish accent on it and then
three weeks three months later i come
back to paris i want to work and live
there and i go back to the hotel
and i see the guy he goes ah the
irishman is back and he goes yeah and i
said i'm looking for a job and he goes
well as an irishman you can work here
you know we have the common market so
you can be a receptionist in my hotel
and can i see your passport and go well
you know it's a little streaky oh it's
all right i'll pay you under the table
right so i think fine i'm going to be in
i'm going to be in paris i have this job
it's where all the models stay when they
come to paris
22. i'm so happy i'm excited right
and then stupid me i didn't realize that
english people come to this hotel and i
couldn't get away with my french with
kind of a little bit of a weird irish
accent to it i had to fool english
people and irish people were coming to
the hotel and i had to have an irish
accent right
so what did i start doing
there was conveniently this is this
hotel's still there it's in the french
quarter latin quarter i go to there was
a pub right across the way and i would
go into this pub and i kind of observed
the people and i listened to their
way they talked and i saw the way they
dressed and their mannerisms i started
dressing like them i bought the kind of
black pants that they all kind of wore i
sort of saw certain gestures i went to
the library and i researched an entire
past for me i was born in dublin on this
particular street i went to this school
i started this professor i had it all
down right
i got really really good at it and at
one point i started dating an irish girl
the story is catch me if you can
the story is totally true and i had
people who could corroborate it
and um and she thought that it was a
little bit strange like the accent was a
she could sell a little bit off i said
well i spent a lot of time in new york
you know oh okay you know she believed
me
and then like my parents came to paris
to visit me it was like a monty you know
like uh faulty towers type episode
i had to like go speak with them they'd
come visit and i speak to them and i'd
returned to the hotel and i would speak
in my irish accent
anyway the whole point of it was and
this went i'm leaving out many many
adventures along the way my point of
view is i have multiple personality
disorders well kind of
but also
i understood how you can make people
believe anything
because they want to believe it nobody
wanted to believe that there was
somebody who was faking this
with me and one girlfriend that i had
i got so sick of trying to pretend to be
an irishman at some point she was a
dutch girl i said
look i'm not really irish you know i'm
american
she got so angry
like i had i like pulled the wool over
her eyes she like ran out she never
talked to me again and i really liked
her it was like so okay i got to be
careful i can't let anybody see through
this
but people want to believe while she
like drew on her eyebrows and put on
fake eyelashes and and had a push-up bra
it's like everything you're doing is a
lie
i never thought of it that way thank you
you're welcome
so anyway people want she's like great
i'm 46.
and i told you i was 21.
yeah
but anyway people want to believe your
story right so if you if you're
moderately good at it and you feel like
you you kind of conv i convinced myself
at one point that i was kind of irish
even though i'm jewish from los angeles
right and i kind of got caught up in the
whole story
but my hope the point of it was
it's actually quite easy to deceive
people and we're biologically there's a
biological basis to mirror i think the
mirror neuron thing has kind of been
debunked a little bit but like no it
hasn't really
who debunked it i don't know me just now
i've decided it's fooey no i think i
brought it up with the uh just because
of the the neuroscience here's the
problem with science
is that oh i agree it's science i
already agree with you science is
science for like two years and then it's
fiction i know i know i know you guys
and then they go back to the same ideas
that they contradicted like i love you
scientists who are like we know the
truth and two years later like none of
that was true we just we just found out
turns out leeches don't clean your blood
you're like dude
so it's like it's medicine it's like
that's why it's called a practice it's
not called the championships it's not
you know
so
um yeah i'm obsessed with people's uh
inherent desire to be conned and that
maybe is in you talk about this a lot
like
the antithesis is the
avoidance of discomfort and conflict
like i just want this to be true so i
don't have to like argue with you about
it or like feel unsafe
but that's putting you in an unsafe
situation ironically
what putting you in like to go along
with a con you know what i mean it's
like i'm doing this to try to
be safe to not have to have an
uncomfortable situation but in so doing
i am my contribution to my future self
is i'm in bed with a con artist now but
you don't know that yeah
because you're self-deceiving yeah
how do you know when you're
self-deceiving
well i mean uh you know i got very good
at it but i'm sure there were signs that
there was that i was trying a little bit
too hard and if you scratch the surface
a little bit you could have figured it
out i mean i was giving clues left right
and center that i really wasn't what i
appeared to be
i hope i'm not totally ruining my
reputation now
not on this in the slides by the way
look at the way that i read your books i
feel like i've written more in your
books than you have oh well tell me
something there's more i'm just looking
at all my little notes
um
uh madonna i just had like things
written about madonna
trend of authenticity
like there's this sort of thing now
where everyone's like i need to be
authentic
what is that what what is that
do ya
all right well
i know you know we're never
really authentic is the is the truth
because i think saying that is
manipulative too it's like i'm being
authentic it's like no you're being
manipulative by trying to say you're
authentic so now i have no ground to
stand on because you're trying to say
you're being authentic and that is your
truth and now you're trying to turn me
into
a bully by saying that right
so the moment we where we become
socialized and we deal with other people
we become an actor right
and you can tell this in your own life
when you're in front of your boss if you
work for a boss you put on a different
persona you have a different mask you
talk differently than when you're with a
colleague or with an intimate partner
you become somebody else
you're continually acting in a
day-to-day fashion that's what it means
to interact with other people you put on
a particular mass that fits the crowd
right
and so
the thing is you never really know who
you are authentically what is truly me
deep down inside because we're so um
reflecting we're always we're so in
tuned with what's going on in the
culture with what our parents tell us
who we are
if you thought about it who really are
you what is that authentic self that is
you it's not it's not like an equation
it's like something you can know
easily or you can just simply think
about right we're kind of mysteries to
ourselves
you know so if you think about who is
the authentic me it's kind of not clear
right and when you're in a social
situation you're not really being
authentic
right you're performing
just get over the fact that you're
constantly performing it's a good thing
i like the fact that we're actors i like
the performance aspect of it some people
are really good actors
that's what makes them seductive that's
what makes them charismatic right
they're kind of conscious about a
certain quality that attracts people and
they kind of know how to emphasize and
accentuate it
why do we revere actors in our culture
why do we give them so much money and so
much celebrity so much attention like
you
because we'd secretly admire their
ability to to take on to assume these
different roles to become different
people we wish we could have that kind
of skill well that's that's so
fascinating to me because it's like when
people are like
you know you're acting anyway all the
time in life yeah and then everyone's
like i have anxiety i have stress i'm
scared i'm like you're already act like
you don't
thank you
just act like you don't you know what i
mean like i take a contrary action we
say this in 12-step programs take a
contrary action like just pretend you
just lie
you know it's like good lying i think
there's such a thing as good lying i'm
having fun i'm having a good time
i like this person or
i'm confident like you know a lot i a
lot of what i have achieved whatever it
is is me pretending i'm not scared when
i'm scared out of my mind i'm like
believe me i can totally understand i'm
just gonna pretend to be someone who's
not and like you know rogan
you know said this once i think way more
eloquently than i would you it's like
sometimes i just have to do the shortcut
that's like
if you're watching a movie
and the person was in the situation
you're in
and you're writing the movie what would
you write the actor to do if they were
the hero of the movie
and just do that
like do what do what a hero in a movie
would do in your situation whether it
was like break up with that guy break up
with that girl you know get out of the
car sell the house whatever the the
thing is that you're scared of doing
yeah write the movie about that thing
and then go you know what the most
badass thing that robert downey jr would
do is his iron man is he would just do
this and this and this and he would
leave and he would say i quit or
whatever
and just do that
you know and
even if you're scared just pretend
you're not yeah and then deal with the
aftermath later it's just like close
your eyes and jump you know and i've
done that so many times but maybe
that's
you know the ability to do that is a
confluence of
you know ancestral you know epigenetic
imprinting
ancestral
you know history courage trauma and
neurochemicals and whatever like why can
some people
jump off a diving board for the first
time
and not be scared and some can't maybe
it's why can alex honold the guy that
climbs the
the rocks
without a string
you know
without being scared yeah there's you
know maybe
it's a lot of it's neurological too our
ability to tolerate that
one moment of like extreme sometimes you
just need one moment of like extreme
bravery right and push through it yeah
just do it the like warrior spirit which
some of us are just wired to be the
warriors and some of us just aren't and
you're a warrior right you're a warrior
princess
for cert thank you
for certain things yeah certain things i
choose not to warrior with uh-huh
but you're basically pretty fearless you
know how to kind of
enter a situation
and and just kind of go for it and not
think about it first and just kind of
overcome your own fears about something
i just transmute i just think fear is
energy and i use it i translate that's a
great way of putting it i just use it as
energy i'm like oh that's fuel fear is
always just fuel for me right it's fuel
or it's information yeah fear is either
leave thank you oh thank you for that oh
my god i thank you for i should turn
around right i should stop talking to
this bird i should leave this alley you
know it's either information or it's a
mem old and it's like i have fear
but i'm in the grocery store why would i
appear in a grocery store this makes no
sense it's well lit there's food
everywhere i've this is the most
nourished i could be this is the
furthest from death i could be
why would i have fear this must be old
and um
or it's
primordi i think studying neurology
which i was forced to after my parents
had strokes and
you know the migraine stuff
it was like uh
i had i had to learn oh that's just
adrenaline and that's just my butt oh i
can just like use that
it's energy money and i'm just gonna
spend it right like efficiently
and then also i think we
emotional intelligence is such a tricky
thing because i think we sometimes
call things the wrong things we
misidentify our feelings the same way
when you you know meet a person that
you're like i have butterflies that's
like um love it for sight no that's
probably just fear
and it's masquerading as you're smiling
and doing all you know and flirting and
arching your back and putting your tits
out because your body's trying to stay
safe around a dangerous person but like
you're actually
attracting and peacocking like it's you
know you we've been brainwashed to
believe that it's the opposite it's like
a it's like a dyslexic instinct or
something it's like mis
misnamed um the same way greenland and
iceland were conflated oh i see um
will you come back when the podcast
studio's done the new one
i'll come back whenever you want i'm
your i'm your s word
because i have so much more stuff now
older people with experience looked down
upon what's the biological basis for
ageism
are you asking me a question no i'm
reading i'm reading the notes that i
wrote what is the biological basis for
ageism i mean there is a biological
basis i'm just kind of obsessed with
that like some of the like like when
you're like racism why would anyone be
racist it's so stupid it's not
profitable it makes businesses run well
ageism is is really really weird because
believe it or not you're going to become
you're going to be elderly or old at
some point as well yeah right yes it's
not like i'm going to i'm gonna become a
different race yeah because you're not
gonna become asian yeah yeah you are
gonna become old at some point it will
become the thing you hate yeah
but there's a biological basis for it
right because there's only you know in
tribal times there's a limited amount of
food so if you start hating the older
people resenting them they're taking up
the food like the way that moose for
example like the older ones you know the
younger ones start having to kill the
older ones because if there's
overpopulation they start grazing they
start taking up too much of the food
killing the grass and like they've got
to go
yeah but you know there's a culture
that's that's too reveres youth too much
right
so
you know since we're all going to get
older and you know i'm kind of in that
category now myself you know that i'm
past 60.
um
you know there's you've got to you want
to feel comfortable you want to feel
good about that you want to feel that
there's something worthwhile about being
older so that you're not afraid of it so
when you're in your 30s or in your 40s
you go it's not so bad to turn 60. it's
actually pretty great because in our
culture we kind of revere wisdom
and experience and people who have
learned the hard way you know when you
get older
the first thing that happens to you is
that you have to deal with a lot of
people dying
and suddenly in my my world people are
dying left right so that i know that i
was very close to had a very close
friend recently who died about a year
ago right it's very traumatic and you
you understand what that's like and it
teaches you something and it creates
a kind of wisdom about life a certain
philosophy towards life about how
ephemeral it is and how precious it is
right so
if if we could turn that value around it
would be incredibly important for us i
think to actually
think look forward to something in
getting older that there are certain
experiences that are worth having when
you're older and you know a lot of older
people are kind of daughtering they
repeat themselves they do become rigid
and there's kind of a negative aspect of
that but there are a lot of young people
who are more rigid and more conventional
than people in their 60s and 70s you
know
so as i get older maybe it's because i i
am getting older but i think that there
there should be something i'm kind of
embracing it yeah i'm kind of happy
about it you know i don't think there's
anything wrong i'm obsessed with getting
older like i i was talking about this
the other day we did this this june
shine launch for this thing and i was
like
i feel like now that i'm with
because with age i have this new wisdom
that ever i've read every book i went to
every therapist i went to every alanon
meeting every day meaning every 12-step
program no one could tell me shit
in terms of cutting out toxic people
or how to stay in my lane or before you
solve a problem first make sure it's
your problem and to not take things
personally like we did this launch event
and i was like
five years ago
it would have been a disaster because i
would have had toxic people there they
would have made it about them there
would have been 10 people being like
where are you why didn't you talk to me
at the party why didn't like it was i
was like getting older i feel like i'm
i'm on drugs i feel like i'm an lsd all
the time because i'm like
it's so much more fun because i don't
waste time on the dumb shit oh good yeah
you know what i mean it's you have you
get this sort of like tunnel vision
where you're like look at those roses
look at that hawk and you see you're
like a stoner
because you're like you know what
matters and you're not like why did he
text me that why did she send that text
without an exclamation mark it was a
period not an exclamation mark and then
spend 45 minutes on that maybe it's
prozac i do go on prozac
i know i was i was in australia once of
sydney a few years ago and i was out
going out with these guys and they
wanted to take me to this club or
something and i said i don't want to go
to this club i'm you know i'm i'm tired
and i got jet lagging oh come on it's
going to be really fun it'll be great
you have to go there and i go look
one of the great things about getting
older is you can't be guilted into doing
things you don't want so fuck off i'm
not going to your stupid party i know
i'm not going to have fun i'm going back
to my hotel room and i'm going to sleep
and 20 years ago i wouldn't have been
able to say that i kind of know what
matters now as i get older there's i
know how that story ends
like i know how that night ends
i'm really working up a hunger with all
these interesting questions and all this
active listening and i'm getting smarter
but i could get even smarter with better
brain food brain food is the key i
wasted so much of my life eating trash
and being a dum-dum yup okay i second
that
but
rude well well if you had gone to the
grocery store when i asked you to i
might have had brain fruit back i got
you enough dip back when you were my
assistant
you didn't wouldn't go to the grocery
store so i almost starved delivery
delivery services they didn't at that
time well i needed an intern i don't
think
is the best time to be an assistant
you missed the boat by like five years
oh fuck like you missed amazon
friendship
every delivery service i think you had
to call doctors on the phone you don't
even need you don't need an assistant
she doesn't listen to this she's never
seen a show yeah
and if and if i get mad about it she'll
just be like sounds like a you problem
that's her motto grace said that to me
the other day sounds like a you problem
my problem is you want something done
right you got to do it yourself your job
to solve my problems
i mean thank god for ritual where all
vitamins are in one place because no one
will help get food in my mouth yeah and
the protein powder no one yeah okay so
the protein powder is such a game
changer so i've been taking the pills
the uh omega pills forever they just
come to my before at a podcast by the
way yeah probably why i'm good at having
a podcast because it grew my brain
because i was taking those ritual
vitamins and they have little mints in
them so
i would smell like a fish quarry
brackish fish right here's the thing
they now have a protein powder i take it
with me on the road they do need to make
little travel packs because i just carry
the whole damn thing i look like a
heroin mule um
and i just take it wherever i go and
then i get a smoothie like the one i'm
holding up right now and then i just put
it in here and mix it up even if i don't
have a blender uh we're gonna show you a
video in a hot second but i think a
cooking video
yeah yeah you're a chef it's a
one-of-a-kind visible supply chain which
is very cool you're always going to know
what's in rituals formulas where the
ingredients come from and why they're
included support your daily health
tomorrow as much as today support your
bones brains muscles help maintain
muscle mass it's a thoughtful
formulation clean plant-based formula no
trash no dumb sugar no syrup high syrup
corn syrup bread number five bullshit
created to support all your nutrient
needs for different life stages 18 plus
pregnancy postpartum and uh us 50 plus
20 grams of pea protein plus god i love
a pea
i love you know what i eat frozen peas
as a snack
and
really to do you chase is that what you
eat after your bundt cake
every for lunch
and what i like a breakfast pastry i
don't think that's unreasonable i think
it's wild i don't think it's like she
eats birthday cake for breakfast we're
gonna need ritual we're in the airport
the other day and you go i just can't
figure out what your eating disorder is
and i go i don't have one and you were
like i think maybe you don't
complete amino acid profile made with
essential choline to help fill in common
dietary gaps your hair is very thick and
healthy i mean you must be healthy so
here's me making it backstage at a show
and i think green bay this is how i do
it
can i help you what are you doing
i'm putting
oh ritual
i just don't have oh there's a scooper
in here that's right
yeah
were you gonna use that knife yes i was
well i don't have a blender in here we
need to start putting in my ryder um
blender
so that i can i put i get smoothies
before the shows and i put my ritual in
my smoothie what else do you want to
know and then you you should get a
shaker bottle so you can just shake it
up i don't know how are you for blenders
by the time you told me to do that you
could have maybe just ordered it you
could have ordered your shaker bottle
uh-huh but do not have enough energy
because you're not uh
using the protein powder i don't have
enough energy because you're dreaming
the life out of me give me some of that
ritual powder and i'll just i'll just
i'll use the scoop
right into my mouth is it weird i just
snort it
is it weird that i like it when it's
kind of like lumpy and chunky it's weird
that you're putting that knife in your
mouth that i found on the floor well
it's covered in ritual protein powder so
oh it's going to have to be good for you
i'm not scared it makes anything
good for you yeah this is my people like
to ask me about my pre-show
routine
this is it i'd like to tell people that
it does look a lot different if you if
you don't half-ass the mixing
but it gets in there
this is like the only way i can no chug
two shows a night at 39 years old
i actually like not blending it i like
when there's little chunks you like
chewing it
that didn't come off right i like when
there are little chunks in my mouth um
yeah i like when there's like little
like
i don't know they're like little curds
little ritual curds
i have like a
a chewy soup it's like a bisque
ritual strawberry smoothie bisque
they're gonna love that i know it's
gonna say i don't i think ritual is
gonna drop us out for this this is what
i do before shows people always ask like
how are you doing 50 cities in a row and
two shows a night at 39 years old with
all the stuff you do and
then having to deal with benton all day
long which is obviously emotionally
exhausting
oh god the camera cut out so weird oh
interesting the camera
yeah it cut out but why it wasn't on you
it cuts off on your face
it is crazy that you travel with this
though she only packs this in her
suitcase yeah i do
oh yeah there's a
tsa took it out
and like tested it
so why not shake up your ritual i mean
you're i mean look at that who wouldn't
want that life and everyone there is
eating cheese yeah eating a ritual i was
i was having my curds yeah cheese curds
cheese ritual curds i'm telling you
that's your next product i'm just saying
i'd like to eat it on the ground floor
that
take my money
i know it sometimes trying new things
can be kind of scary
the key is just make it a habit you know
i mean you gotta do twenty then it just
becomes a habit but they offer a money
back guarantee if you're not 100 in love
that's a power move plus my listeners
get to 10 off during you just got 10
minutes off of your life
from us talking this long but you also
get 10 off during your first three
months just visit ritual.com whitney to
add essential protein today that's
ritual.com
whitney
oh i almost fell asleep that took
forever i wish i had a sleep crown sleep
crown i don't
they came to me because i i promoted
their products so
no i don't know what you want to get
paid for this i feel like i owe sleep
crap money this is a
pillow
that is they sent it to me years ago
because i talked about how i couldn't
sleep yeah an insomniac i had like a
legitimate lunesta addiction i was like
smoking we still couldn't sleep that's i
still couldn't sleep yeah and by the way
i have to nap during the days because i
break up my day into two days so i need
to be able to take a nap at any moment
yeah i like to lay down i like to people
are like when he's so busy she works
hard i'm i'm a layered girl
i lay yeah i like to think i like to
collect myself and it's a pillow that is
somewhat weighted and the outside of it
is this like t-shirt material
and it hugs your face and and it i don't
know how they do this it's always a
little bit cold
it's it's magic you put it on your face
blocks out all light yep and muffle
sound which we could use which we could
use right now because of course you can
hear the quarry of course so it does a
little pressure over the top of your
head which relaxes your body for
sleeping honestly it has saved me for
headaches migraines put it on completely
pitch black it's like an eye mask ear
plugs and a wig like a weighted blanket
all in one you almost forgot your sleeve
crown i would never forget my sleep
crown that's the most important part of
sleep it's the only reason i can sleep
yeah i know me too
this is how i sleep with it here see
look i've started doing this now i i put
it here
so that it's just ah
and then
this is how i nap with it over my head
hugging my head look at that i know i
love mine isn't it the best and it's
cold somehow and this is how i nap
before the show and then when i come
home
it's right here uh hugging my face
covering my ears so that i can't hear
anyone having sex in the hotel or any
random i can't even hear my own inner
monologue
oh because you're too comfortable sleep
crowns they know that 75 people are side
sleepers which by the way not great not
good but that's what you are and we made
sure that the sleep crown works
perfectly for you and fixes the fact
that you sleep on your side and that's
terrible for your shoulders and neck and
everything uh and your boobs by the way
and your face yes horrible unless well i
if i sit on my side i put my skin up and
then put it down
there's soft squishy or whatever skin
this is uh they're soft squishy they're
handmade in the united states just like
me
for just like your boyfriend soft
squishy made in the u.s
for 15 off and free shipping in the us
you're not free shipping you're
expensive to move uh go to sleep
crowd.com whitney and use promo code
whitney what are you waiting for they
even have travel sleep crowns pj
loungers and pillow mist spray to give
you a sense of calm while you drift to
sleep that's sleep crown.com whitney
promo code whitney for 15 off free
shipping of the united states uh sleep
crown.com whitney promo code whitney
you'll thank us when you wake up game
it's a game changer
oh but and back to robert green and my
lava in my head
not corroborated by yeah
at all last question i know i'm letting
you have to why does asia
uh and i'm just gonna say asia
like no because you know me i
i love the look i get like
i know but i do like
same freaking questions over and over
and over again uh i've not been asked
these questions ever before
i can honestly say that i've never had
these questions before but you know that
i'm an animal rescue nut and it drives
me insane sort of in the asian cultures
like the treatment of of many animals
and the gallbladders and the of the
bears and the dogs and
i work with this um organization
slaughterhouse survivors uh that's
helping shut down the slaughterhouse
survive the the dog meat market that
really is a suicide no no
and um
and you know you have to get in the head
of the people that are doing this you
know like in africa when they're
poaching elephants
i'm like how can someone do this i can't
i can't but it's the same way in america
where you go
where where you know people in coastal
cities and that are affluent want to go
like what is it with these middle
americans with their guns it's like
well that's classist because you're not
you you haven't been in this state you
don't know what it's like like you're
you're it's not like
people buy guns to be like i hope some
kid goes and shoots up a school with
their gun like these are people that
maybe you know don't have security
systems that are you know
you know 200 miles from the nearest
police station you're you're you're
they're just just as just as a thought
experiment
the same way but there's no excuse for
cruelty to animals none and here's what
i'll say exactly but in a lot of times
in africa
this is because i have to try to
understand why they're doing it in order
to dismantle it you have to know so if
you're saying if you get me this ivory
tusk
you can feed your children right or
there was a there was an article in the
um probably new york times i'm pretty
sure about um
why we don't cry for lions in africa and
it was about a mother and she was saying
that in africa lions are like coyotes
and and your kid can be walked home from
school and get attacked by a lion you
know so if you're if you're telling if
if coyotes come after mona i'm going to
kill the coyote and i have absolutely no
guilt about it and i feel fine so if
you're saying that my child coyote would
go after ramona yeah well mona yeah mona
would come up yeah
real but what coyotes do they're so
cunning what they do is they ingratiate
themselves one will and then 14 will
like descend you know
so um so if you're telling me oh
and i'm like why would you kill a lie
and that's awful and because it was it
attacks our kids on the way home from
school you know i'm like okay got it
it's more of a nuisance or you're
killing elephants because you need to
eat and you're in this fight or flight
mode and you're like i can feed my
entire family if i kill this elephant
whatever um
i have to get in the brain space of it
so i was trying to get the brain space
of this the korean uh the
the dog meat stuff and they are so far
removed from the i and we do it with
pigs you know like the korean dog meat
festival they look because they value
pigs in a different certain cultures
value pigs and they look at the way that
we eat bacon and they're like
how can you come for us about a dog meat
festival when you guys eat pigs that are
even more intelligent than dogs you know
so
just the things that we are able to the
cognitive dissonance we can you know
sleep at night with but
point being
they were like well we don't understa
the person i was talking to that was
like the cultural sort of helping me
understand you know
the way you treat your old people is
disgusting to them
the way the way the idea that you put a
a bear in a cage and take their
gallbladder my brain is like that is the
most disgusting and you they're like
well you put your old people in a
nursing home
to rot
and i'm like what do you mean there's
someone there's someone help you and
that's like they look down at that and
one of those the flight that crashed
right one of them was
that um it was in
uh i don't remember what the the flight
was that crashed in asia
that
the guy deferred to the elder the
co-pilot deferred because to disrespect
an elder is so looked down upon you
would never so in the when they got the
black box basically it was like that was
i think south korean south korea yeah
like if if it you never disrespect an
elder you know i was flying to hong kong
once and i was with this guy that he did
like digital
something and he was saying focus groups
in doing focus groups in asia for their
products is kind of like pointless
because everyone's just going to defer
to the oldest person in the room
for their opinion like it's hard to get
feedback because they'll be like so what
do you think of this thing and i'll just
look to the older person and whatever he
says they'll agree with well i have to
move there
but just sort of it was like that just
the disrespect
you know um
like is there any like historical
reasoning for that like i just was
curious as someone historical reasoning
for what for why
asia
has respects their elders the way they
do and we don't the way we do is it like
a weather thing a climate thing
is it getting a con
it's not genghis khan i think america is
you know are you a young oh right right
right and we're all about the individual
and we've always kind of celebrated
people who kind of are rugged and can
get things for themselves and are kind
of self-reliant
and we don't have deep roots like they
do in france or other countries that
have deep cultural roots so we've always
had a history of a youth culture and i
think the first yeah the the birth of
the fir of our youth culture was really
in the 1920s it even goes further back
than that but you know in 1920s it was
all about you know the the uh flappers
etc and people were going kind of crazy
the great gatsby
and people started to really revere
young people and then after world war ii
it became like capitalism was all about
advertising to young people and we
created a youth culture
that doesn't really exist in asia they
have kind of the opposite sort of thing
where elders are very much respected and
you see that when you when you go to
europe still to this day you know and
the children are raised differently you
can kind of see it in the children the
children aren't so bold and kind of
bratty as they are here you know and i
kind of like when i meet
kids who are raised differently who kind
of have that slight touch of humility um
so you know there's something kind of
calm but kind of calm spirit
whereas the american kids don't seem to
have a center they're so all they're so
nervous they've got all this nervous
energy
you know so i think there's a cultural
thing to that
what's it laughing am i answering your
question what's the weirdest feel like
i'm answering what's the way i never
feel like i ask a coherent question what
who what's the weirdest country weirdest
country not negative but just what's the
weirdest place
like the place where because you've
researched every country every person
every leader like the weirdest tradition
the weirdest
and weirdest obviously subjective
well i don't know i mean i've been to
every place kind of has its its weird
customs
you know i i was in moscow for a book
tour and moscow was one of the strangest
places i've ever been to i thought it
thought it was like on another planet
like
simulator 101 yeah
no it's actually very beautiful the
architecture is so weird i've never seen
architecture gingerbread yeah house
beautiful stuff you know all these onion
kind of domes and things
and then the the cars and the traffic is
so different from anything there they
don't have like stop lights and they
don't have taxis you just hail any old
driver down the street and they you pay
them you know and kind of thing and and
they're like prostitutes everywhere and
you never know which one is you know
when they come up to you
and then they took me to like a siberian
sauna
which was a really intense experience
like you feel like you've been reborn
they like put you in this incredibly
claustrophobic sauna room and this guy
comes in with a giant
palm leaf or something starts beating
you on your back
and then he takes you out and he dips
you in a beard hammer and he takes you
and puts you in a barrel of cold water
and then takes you out and puts you back
in the heat and then kind of rubs you
down i was like afterwards i was like an
ecstasy this was the greatest experience
of my life i felt like i had been reborn
they put you like an intentional trauma
yeah
so i thought moscow was like going to
another planet you know i thought it was
pretty exciting
in the middle east
yeah is really wild like the relation
the the patriarchy is still so strong
like this woman who's kind of leading me
around i'm saying why are you always
walking behind me
i'm not used to women walking behind me
she said well that's how you know that's
how we're trained you know i thought it
was
maybe kind of like i'm looking at it
she's like i'm looking at your butt
that's what i told myself i know i get
in trouble all the time for that they're
like women can't drive over here and
they can't work and like that sounds
awesome
[Laughter]
you say that sounds amazing yeah
if i just say it
i know cancel me
um okay so i can't uh the daily laws
this is for uh the people with add like
me
um did you want me to explain it yeah
are we done yes no explain it i'll be
very brief don't or not
well basically um you know i have an
idea of a certain kind of attitude
towards life that's very powerful and
it's kind of in all of my six of my
books and that attitude is being
realistic
so you're able to kind of look at
yourself and say this is who i am you
cut through all the bullshit of what
your parents told you about what other
people tell you about what the culture
tells you in social media and you're
able to realistically understand your
strengths and your weaknesses what you
were meant to accomplish in life you can
also be realistic about the people
around you so you can have that instinct
that whitney talks about you can sense
this person is toxic i'm not getting
involved with them
so instead of projecting onto everybody
around you your wishes you can actually
see through them and see who they are
and then you see the the world itself
and what's going on in the world the
zeitgeist with a degree of realism you
know what's going on in your particular
line of work where politics are headed
with that kind of realistic ad able to
see through into yourself into other
people and into the world at large it's
incredibly powerful
and so
this book i'm taking all of those ideas
and i'm kind of condensing them to every
day you have kind of a meditation that's
going to kind of ground you in this
realism that i think is so powerful it's
kind of like a straight shot of like
you might not like this but this is the
truth let me save you 10 years of
like let's cut the shit
it's like if i had this when i was 21 i
would like look so much younger um so i
think it's it like the idea for me is
like this is like to me like 10 years of
therapy 10 years of like neuroscience
studying and history all like in one
place
and
if you want to win at anything in life
whether it's like you want to be a
florist or you want to be a ceo it's
just like
i'm going to give it to you straight
right i'm not going to lie to you
because i respect you enough to just
tell you the truth emily and i
i tried to have a conversation with her
earlier like this and she thought i was
trying to fire her
because i cried i was like let me give
it to you so i cried
what law of power is crying all the time
that's the that's the surrender tactic
that's the truth play a sucker to catch
a sucker yes
sometimes the best battle strategy is a
masterful retreat
um so it's like cut the shit i mean it's
it's like he's just not that into you
like
it's um
you know like when a girl's like
he's not texting me back well maybe he
just likes you too much he doesn't he's
not into you like let me just give it to
you straight i'm not going to use kid
gloves this is how to survive in the
world and get everything that you want
i'm not happy about it i'm not biased
this is just how human nature works is
that psychology works is how life works
this is what works for all the winners
in the past like easily digestible here
and if this yeah i wish i had this
fucking 20 years ago
well you've done pretty well for
yourself you had it 20 years ago maybe
things wouldn't have worked out
so many people would be dead yeah
things happen for a reason and they
turned out quite well for you i must say
you're the best yeah
so
so you're gonna come back uh with your
sublime book
yeah when i'm about 75 years old which
you're gonna ride on my porch or my deck
yeah yeah i'm already
about one fifth of the way through god
sounds awful oh my god
i don't know how you do it um
i end these awkwardly as you know i
start them awkwardly
and the whole thing's awkward frankly
i just say end the podcast awkwardly
well i think you've done that
don't ride elephants
[Music]
wow
[Applause]